There you go.
Excuse me.
Oh, excuse me, sir.
Are you
sitting in 26G?
Yes.
Have I done
something wrong?
No, no, no, no,
we just wanted to ask
if you would mind
switching seats
so that a mother and a child
could sit together.
But I'm back there.
Right, yeah, but you'd
actually be sitting here...
[gentle harp flourish]
Which is
in Economy Plus.
It's actually
an upgrade.
Upgrade, you say.
Mm-hmm.
Economy Plus.
Yes, sir.
Oh.
Don't mind
if I do.
Great, great.
Carry-on?
Carry on
yourself, Alex.
Thank you.
[classical music]
Economy Plus.
Mm, for the discerning
passenger.
[chuckles]
We're not
in Kansas anymore, Toto.
(man over PA)
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is your captain speaking.
We should be leaving Topeka
in the next ten minutes.
I stand corrected.
Looks like we're gonna have
a smooth flight.
Trust me,
I know the captain,
and he is, uh,
one smooth guy.
- [scoffs]
- [chuckles]
[laughing]
Of course
he knows the captain.
He is the captain.
Oh-ho-ho!
Ho! Oh!
Move over,
Colin Mochrie.
There's a new face
in the biz.
His name is Captain.
[laughing]
Have to be in Economy Plus
to get it, I guess.
[sighs]
Extra foot room.
One inch at least.
Mm.
Sky Shoppe magazine.
[chuckles]
Don't mind if I do.
Oh, dog-eared
for my convenience.
Lord of the Rings cups.
Lord of the Rings tables.
Oh. Oh!
Oh!
Holy shiatsu massage!
[laughs]
Economy Plus!
It hurts a little,
but--but I like it.
[crying]
Wrong spot.
[snoring]
[airplane rattling]
[thunder rumbling]
[thunder booms]
[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪
Hmm.
And I thought
I had an upgrade.